hier de l'ukraine la fin des manoeuvres
de certaines forces en crimée un retrait
avait déjà été annoncé mardi le ministre
britannique de la défense affirme ce
matin qu'il n'y a pour l'instant aucune
preuve même son cloche à washington où
joe biden continue ses mises en garde
contre une éventuelle attaque russe en
ukraine pour faire le point sur ces
annonces on va prendre tout de suite la
direction de moscou bonjour elena
volochine les autorités russes on voit
donc un nouveau signe de détente
alors c'est toujours le même signe qu'on
voit depuis avant-hier lorsque le
ministre russe de la défense sergueï
choïgou a annoncé en partie la fin des
manoeuvres militaires et des exercices
militaires de très grande ampleur lancée
par la russie il a par la même occasion
précisé on ne le savait pas auparavant
que presque toute la force de frappe
militaire us étaient mobilisés pour ces
exercices est donc aujourd'hui
effectivement la russie dit qu'elle
retire les troupes partie en exercice en
crimée alors il faut préciser plusieurs
choses la crimée d'abord c'est cette
péninsule annexée est prise à l'ukraine
par la russie en 2014 ou la russie
depuis a fortement renforcé son
contingent militaire il y avait déjà une
base navale militaire russe en russie en
crimée depuis l'époque soviétique sur la
base d'un accord avec l'ukraine mais
depuis l'annexion cette base a été très
fortement renforcées et donc dans le
cadre de ces manoeuvres militaires la
russie avait envoyé en plus des
contingents et des effectifs militaires
des équipements des troupes en crimée
donc pour ces exercices et elle affirme
retirer ses troupes si vous l'avez dit
les états unis et l'occident sont
prudents quant à ces annonces et pour
cause il y à ici à moscou un groupe
d'investigation le conflit intelligence
team qui surveillent les déplacements de
l'armée russe et son chef a affirmé en
observant en étudiant les images
satellites en recueillant des
témoignages
en recoupant par ses investigations les
nouvelles manoeuvres militaires russes
il a affirmé qu' au contraire la russie
avait renforcé encore plus en fin de
semaine dernière ses effectifs aux
frontières de l'ukraine est donc lui
aussi se montre très prudent quant à ses
annonces il dit qu'il va falloir dans
les prochains jours surveiller que
réellement la russie fait ski 10 c'est à
dire qu'elle fait rentrer ses
contingents militaires partis en
exercice dans leur base de dislocation
permanente bonjour elena des escales à
de réels ou pas les jours à venir le
diront ce qui est certain en revanche
c'est que vladimir poutine est resté
maître du tempo du déroulé de cette
crise de cette séquence
alors dans la mesure où quoi qu'il en
dise il a brandi la menace militaire et
fait trembler le monde entier par une
éventuelle attaque de grandin grande
échelle contre l'ukraine oui on peut
dire que dans ce cas là
l'état qui est dans cette position est
en position de force maintenant il a
rencontré face à lui une oxydantes
réunit très déterminé à ne pas laisser
faire cette invasion avec notamment on
l'a entendu tous ces derniers jours avec
les diplomates et notamment olaf scholz
en visite hier à moscou des des
sanctions très dures que préparait
l'union européenne en cas d' attaques de
l'ukraine avec les états unis qui
promettent une réponse très forte donc
potentiellement une réponse de l'otan et
donc il va falloir voir le comment va se
dérouler comment vont continuer à se
dérouler ces pourparlers mais on voit
que vladimir poutine est tout de même en
difficulté quant à ses exigences
vis-à-vis des etats-unis et de l'otan de
nos élargissement de l'otan de retrait
des troupes américaines des pays
d'ex-union soviétique où ils sont
stationnés sur la base du fait que ces
pays ont rejoint l'otan depuis 1997 on
voit que l'occident que les etats-unis
l'otan ont opposé une fin de
non-recevoir à vladimir poutine pour
l'heure ceci n'a pas avancé vladimir
poutine reste ferme sur ses positions
donc on va voir si effectivement il va
réussir à imposer son scénario par la
force ou si cette fois-ci l'occident va
réellement représenté un contrepoids
elena volochine à moscou pour france24
merci beaucoup et l'aisne